[Música]
y con nuestro segundo invitado del día
vamos a hablar de ucrania la situación
sanitaria en ese país y también los
efectos de la guerra sobre la salud de
la población ucraniana vamos a hablar de
todas esas personas que no han podido
continuar de alguna manera con sus
tratamientos médicos a causa de esta
guerra y por supuesto que en esta
conversación con nuestro segundo
invitado al día me acompaña en esta mesa
de trabajo más romeros alamar bienvenida
vamos a hablar entonces de lo que ocurre
en ucrania respecto a toda la salud
porque ayer hablaba me es exactamente
ayer la organización mundial de la salud
te publicó un poco su balance también
después de una visita que hicieron al
país y vamos a repasar esas cifras antes
de empezar con la entrevista se han
registrado casi 200 ataques sobre tanto
la infraestructura como los servicios de
salud el personal de salud también en
general en ucrania desde que empezó la
guerra se calcula que el 40 por ciento
de las familias que ahora mismo viven en
ucrania tienen al menos una persona que
se enferma crónica de alguna enfermedad
y que no puede acceder a los
tratamientos y a los medicamentos
necesarios y por último la cifra más
devastadora quizás que hemos escuchado
son esos 3.000 muertes que calcula
también la ms que han habido a raíz de
esta falta de acceso a tratamientos y de
salud es importante recordar que son
casi tantos como civiles muertos en las
situaciones de conflicto directo también
desde que empezó la invasión rusa sobre
territorio ucraniano así es más
lamentable es todo esto que está
sufriendo el pobre son ucraniana por
cuenta de esta invasión rusa vamos
entonces a saludar a nuestro segundo
invitado del día estamos con daniel
lópez acuña epidemiólogo y el director
de acción sanitaria de la organización
mundial de la salud gracias a niell por
estar con nosotros en este espacio de
france 24 dedicado a la salud en nuestro
invitado del día en esta sección mar
pues si nosotros queríamos empezar
hablando y preguntando también pues
sobre todo alrededor de estas
situaciones de crisis de estos
medicamentos que faltan no además de
ucrania en general cuáles son estos
medicamentos o tratamientos que suelen
hacer más falta y que no se encuentran
ahora mismo en el país
bueno yo creo que lo más importante es
entender qué pasa en la situación
sanitaria cuando se produce un conflicto
cuando hay una guerra y cuando hay una
disrupción del sistema sanitario en su
conjunto no es que sean sólo
medicamentos aislados primero se
interrumpe el acceso regular de las
personas a los servicios de salud y esto
es particularmente importante en
personas que tienen enfermedades
crónicas y que requieren tratamientos
continuos sea diabetes hipertensión
enfermedad cardíaca enfermedad pulmonar
obstructiva crónica cáncer segundo es
que el abasto de insumos básicos para la
producción de servicios se ve afectado
por las acciones bélicas y ucrania por
ejemplo muy al comienzo de la guerra
tuvo una serie de crisis en el acceso a
oxígeno por ejemplo pero toda la
importación de regular de bienes y
servicios sanitarios se ve afectada por
la situación médica y esto altera la
operación de los servicios
por si esto fuera poco encima hay
ataques a las instituciones de
prestación de servicios o como ya lo
señaló anteriormente más de 200 ataques
documentados que violan las reglas de la
guerra y de los principios humanitarios
pero que son una realidad que obliga
primero pues a tener una gran precaución
en las operaciones sanitarias pero
segundo ha de desplegar equipos médicos
estandarizados
acreditados de carácter internacional
cuando no se pueden resolver las cosas
con los recursos locales es decir es una
constelación de factores muy compleja y
por eso tenemos una situación en donde
hay 12 millones de ucranianos que
necesitan asistencia sanitaria con
carácter de emergencia o una acción
humanitaria de refuerzo y por eso la o
ms a lanzado un planteamiento de apoyo a
6 millones de personas en dentro de
ucrania y a los 83 millones de personas
refugiadas que están en países que les
reciben o les acogen en torno a las
fronteras ucrania está claro daniel y
con toda esta situación entonces que se
está viviendo en ucrania que podemos
esperar porque también hay que tomar en
cuenta y no hay que olvidar que estamos
en medio de la pandemia de coronavirus
que no se ha acabado
sí bueno ya teníamos una situación
compleja en ucrania con respecto al
coronavirus y a la vacunación teníamos
antes de que estallara la guerra una
vacunación que no alcanzaba siquiera al
35 por ciento de la población como podrá
imaginarse muy bien con el advenimiento
de la guerra y con la destrucción y la
disrupción en el sistema sanitario ni se
puede continuar vacunando como se venía
haciendo ni se pueden poner las dosis de
refuerzo del caso y lo que tenemos es
una altísima proporción de la población
desprotegida en materia de vacunación en
donde evidentemente también los
contagios proliferan lo que pasa es que
no podemos ni siquiera contarlos porque
sé que está totalmente
sumergido en las acciones bélicas y las
acciones de defensa y esto también
supone un desafío en la población de
refugiados especialmente mujeres y niños
porque hay que extremar las acciones de
protección con vacunación contra el cob
y en esta población pero no es sólo el
kobe ya teníamos en ucrania problemas
relacionados porque la adicción en
ucrania viene deteriorándose desde el
2014 de manera importante cuando hubo la
guerra del donbass y la situación que
teníamos era de una epidemia que fue
importante de sarampión entre los años
2017 y 2019 e incluso la circulación de
poliovirus ligado a la vacuna contra la
polio que puede resultar una amenaza un
riesgo para que puedan surgir brotes de
polio o de parálisis infantil
precisamente por eso también le
queríamos preguntar cómo puede afectar
eso al resto del continente no estamos
hablando que a ucrania tiene tasas de
vacunación muy bajas como decía no solo
por el cohete 1950
enfermedades y europa ha sido un bastión
donde estas enfermedades de hace tiempo
que habían desaparecido o por ejemplo
pues hablando de la polio al menos puede
tener un impacto también por el
movimiento de refugiados en estas
situaciones epidemiológicas del resto
del continente
definitivamente puede tener un impacto
en ningún continente es una isla
epidemiológica ningún país es una isla
epidemiológica este fenómeno lo hemos
visto repetidamente en todos los
conflictos en áfrica medio oriente el
sudeste asiático américa latina' lo que
pasa es que está siendo
relativamente nuevo tras la guerra de
los balcanes hace varias décadas en el
ámbito europeo pero definitivamente la
dinámica epidemiológica tanto del crono
virus como de enfermedades prevenibles
por vacunación como de otras
enfermedades agudas y crónicas la
tuberculosis
multirresistente pues en la medida
y tengan un incremento en su incidencia
y puedan diseminarse ampliamente afectan
al resto del continente al resto del
mundo ahora danielle el derecho a la
salud es algo fundamental incluso
también en los tiempos de guerra cómo se
puede proteger realmente este derecho
porque también estamos viendo que no se
está respetando hemos visto bombardeos a
centros de salud como también usted bien
lo dijo esto puede constituir en un
futuro crímenes de guerra si es
investigado y pues evidenciado que
realmente fueron atacados
deliberadamente
centros de salud en medio de esta guerra
sí yo creo que hay que distinguir entre
dos cosas primero el derecho a la salud
que es muy importante y es el derecho a
que todo ciudadano tenga un acceso a la
prestación de servicios de salud
independiente de su capacidad de pago y
este es un problema ya estructural que
no tiene que ver con la guerra que viene
de 'la de tiempo atrás pero que la
guerra agudiza y está el problema de la
falta de respeto a los principios
humanitarios y a las llamadas leyes de
la guerra que están enmarcadas en los
acuerdos tras la batalla de solferino y
la creación del comité internacional de
la cruz roja que plantean con toda
claridad el que las instalaciones
sanitarias y los profesionales
sanitarios no deben ser atacados en una
situación de guerra y que es una
violación a los derechos humanos a los
derechos humanitarios y a las reglas de
la guerra que constituye un crimen de
lesa humanidad ya veníamos desde hace
varios años con una gran preocupación en
el mundo no solo ucrania con los ataques
a instalaciones sanitarias
el comité internacional de la cruz roja
con un abs viene trabajando en
documentar esto en distintas crisis ha
ocurrido en yemen ha ocurrido en siria a
veces se nos olvida cuando no está tan
cerca de nosotros o tan cerca del ámbito
europeo pero lo que está ocurriendo en
ucrania es también un problema muy serio
un problema que tiene que ser además de
denunciado pues investigado y
adecuadamente sancionado por los ámbitos
internacionales que se ocupan de los
crímenes de guerra precisamente también
en ese sentido no hasta dónde puede
llegar la organización mundial de la
salud de usted que trabajó y que fue ex
directivo para tratar de proteger el
derecho a la salud también para tratar
de perseguir los posibles potenciales
crímenes que hay contra las
instalaciones sanitarias en el contexto
de guerra que podemos esperar para
proteger este este acceso a la salud del
pueblo ucraniano
bueno primero hay que entender que no es
una acción de la organización mundial en
forma aislada es en el marco de la
organización de las naciones unidas en
el marco de distintos organismos que se
ocupan de responsabilidades que a veces
son la atención sanitaria o la atención
humanitaria pero a veces son la
persecución de los crímenes de guerra y
en este caso la oim ese no tiene un
mandato o una atribución para investigar
o perseguir los ataques al personal
sanitario los puede denunciar puede
llamar la atención al respecto pero
corresponde a otros organismos que
tienen que ver con los crímenes de
guerra a la corte penal internacional al
al consejo de derechos humanos de la
organización de las naciones unidas el
poder establecer sanciones a este
respecto ahora la oms tiene mucho por
hacer y está haciendo y este último
llamamiento que plantea la necesidad de
147 millones de dólares para poder
atender con 80 millones la respuesta
inmediata dentro de ucrania de
necesidades críticas
67 y medio millones la respuesta a los
refugiados que se desplazan con la
colaboración de casi 100 agentes
operativos de ongs u otros organismos de
naciones unidas en ucrania y en los
países fronterizos todo eso es una
acción fundamental para y mitigar el
impacto de la guerra para tratar de
garantizar el derecho a la salud porque
insisto
además de los ataques que son por
supuesto más que condenables a las
instalaciones sanitarias la clave está
en garantizar que los ciudadanos
desde menores de edad adultos mujeres y
hombres y tres zonas mayores tengan un
acceso equitativo a la salud ahora
hablemos de a largo plazo no qué
consecuencias va a traer todo este
contexto de guerra y lo que acabamos de
hablar en la salud de los ucranianos los
que se fueron y los que se quedan
bueno yo creo que conocemos muy bien los
impactos que tienen todas las guerras
sobre la salud disminuye la esperanza de
vida hay una mortalidad excesiva
incrementada por actos violentos hay una
mortalidad excesiva que se produce por
la disrupción de los sistemas de salud
se
deterioran todos los programas
preventivos las campañas de vacunación
es decir lo que podemos esperar
perfectamente en el mediano y largo
plazo es un retroceso en la situación de
salud ucraniana en la situación salud de
los ucranianos que emigran también mucho
dependerá de cómo son acogidos y cómo
son atendidos en los países que les
reciben pero hay un desafío muy grande
para darles la atención que necesitan y
para garantizar que en ucrania no se
deteriore aún más la situación de la
prestación de servicios de salud y como
consecuencia la situación de salud de
los ucranianos